j'ai été voir le docteur Lionel ketch
suite à j'avais plusieurs amis qui avait
refait dans chez ce dentiste donc
j'avais vu déjà le résultat sur pas mal
de personnes je me suis pas jeter
n'importe où et moi j'avais un pivot à
changer donc on m'avait conseillé ses
services un pivot c'est
[Musique]
et c'est par la suite en fait que il y a
eu d'énormes problèmes alors pour tout
le monde il vous fait votre pivot non il
me conseille de refaire tout parce que
changer un seul pivot il y aurait trop
de différence il m'a dit je te conseille
de tout refaire parce que même vu ton
activité tu sais Céline Dion Britney
Spears c'est les dents à l'époque
c'était pas la mode c'était pas comme
maintenant c'était pas très pratique
c'était le seul du moins de ce qu'il
avançait à pratiquer ces gens-là
alors donc il vous dit je vous promets
un sourire de star oui ça qui vous a dit
vous a dit vous allez être magnifique je
vais tout refaire et surtout j'aurais
plus de problème plus de pivot à changer
et je serais tranquille donc vous
réfléchissez vous lui dites oui tout de
suite j'avais perdu dentiste de base
comme beaucoup de gens je pense
parce que du coup j'ai plus du tout
confiance en aucun dentiste et donc vous
lui avez dit oui vous lui dit oui on a
commencé les travaux et
du temps quand même en sachant qu'il m'a
tout refait tout complètement
un an après les premières facettes ont
cassées à la veille d'un départ en
vacances donc je la plie en urgence en
me demandant de trouver une solution
donc il m'a fait une d'improvisoire et
c'est proposé de nous le refaire
gratuitement avec encore de nouveaux
modèles donc pas de souci c'est ce qui
s'est passé
et par la suite lorsqu'il a fini mes
travaux j'avais des réglages à faire
donc des réglages qui devaient effectuer
et le jour où je me pointe à mon dernier
rendez-vous en fait je vois la police
tout était sous scellé je comprenais pas
ce qui se passait en fait alors c'est
nous raconter ça parce que c'est cette
histoire est complètement folle ça a
duré combien de temps les travaux
ça a été très rapide parce qu'il me
prenait à 6h du matin tous les jours
ça prend du temps normalement ouais
c'est ça c'est le problème qui est qui a
eu c'est justement par rapport à ça les
infections c'est parce que il y a pas eu
un temps assez long pour la
cicatrisation
son père vous a soigné aussi c'est ça
malheureusement j'ai conseillé à
beaucoup de personnes dont mon papa
d'accord qui à l'heure actuelle galère
pour pouvoir réparer tous les dégâts
qu'il a parce qu'il faut savoir que
maintenant ça fait des années que le
procès qu'on a tous porté plainte on est
plusieurs victimes entre temps il y a
des personnes même qui sont décédées ça
faut penser à ces personnes là c'est
famille là donc il a fait pas mal de
dégâts on attend toujours bien de cause
moi personnellement c'est ce qui
m'intéresse c'est pas le l'argent moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de retrouver un
sourire normal mais dans je sais que je
ne retrouverai plus comme toutes les
autres personnes on va en parler en fait
pour les dégâts qu'il a effectué alors
ils sont ils sont violents pendant vos
soins lorsque mes
il a dû me rouler pour me faire de
nouvelles mais il y avait lui et son
père sur moi en fait avec une
émoj'appelle cymburin parce qu'ils
avaient un espèce de tu marteau il
m'avait endormi toute la bouche avec
plusieurs piqûres et taper taper taper
jusqu'à que ça sorte moi j'avais jamais
connu ça j'avais jamais effectué ce
genre de choses donc
à un moment donné j'entends du qui avait
un truc qui se passait je les ai vu ce
concerter je demandais ce qu'il y avait
il m'avait dit qu'il y a une banque avec
AC et cette dent était vraiment
nécessaire pour tenir
à le bridge en fait c'est il a fait tout
en un bloc en fait c'est même pas dans
pardon ce qui est conseillé
et il m'a dit voilà ça tiendra pas je
préfère te dire un moment donné ça va
casser donc à ce moment-là tu reviendras
me voir je te ferai un dentier ben
gratuitement mais je lui ai dit j'ai 24
ans
et quelques temps après il s'est fait
arrêter alors justement
deux ans plus tard vous avez votre
premier problème avec vos dons ce qui se
passe au départ infection sur infection
ben je vais plusieurs fois aux urgences
je connais des problèmes très graves
dans les drones
c'est compliqué alors
les dégâts la somme c'est même pas la
peine surtout en France comment vous
avez payé déjà pour toute
une somme assez importante on n'a pas
fait ça gratuitement et nous a conseillé
une mutuelle en complément par contre
un peu plus de 6000 euros
et donc par la suite ça a été infection
sur infection j'ai des greffé osseuses à
faire j'ai au minimum 7 implants pour
pouvoir espérer
replacer des facettes parce
qu'aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passe au
niveau de vos dents ce qui se passe
c'est que vu que le procès est en cours
on ne peut pas
du moins par rapport aux devis qu'on a
une majorité des victimes c'est très
élevé beaucoup de dentistes ne veulent
pas faire l'avance de soins ce qui est
tout à fait compréhensible qu'est-ce que
vous avez comme problème parce qu'on
sait pas encore alors quand on voit vos
dents là on se dit vous avez l'air
d'avoir des belles dents en fait j'ai
des infections j'ai comme les dentiste
me voyaient arriver ou les experts on me
dit c'est une
c'est infestée de kyste j'ai des
questions partout d'accord
j'ai grève au sol à faire gencives
et au minimum certaines plans à mettre
pour pouvoir espérer refaire un travail
propre en sachant que on sait pas ce qui
est récupérable ou pas c'est douloureux
extrêmement
tous les jours vous vivez avec une
douleur
on peut plus manger
c'est que liquide faut toujours faire
attention on a toujours peur bec parce
qu'on se retrouve sans rien il y a tout
qui part aujourd'hui on est plus de 10
ans après quand même et toujours rien ça
peut évoluer non ça fait 10 ans que vous
avez des problèmes comme ça plus de 10
ans c'est plus de 10 ans que vous viviez
plus quoi en fait c'est ça ni moi ni mes
proches alors vous n'êtes pas la seule
victime bien sûr que racontez-nous quand
vous arrivez pour un de vos derniers
soins vous arrivez au cabinet et là vous
voyez la police c'est ça ouais je vois
la police tout mettre sous scellé
d'accord récupérer tout ce qui avait
récupéré donc moi je comprenais pas ce
qui se passait
et j'ai pas compris de suite d'ailleurs
c'est par la suite quand je voyais que
tout le monde entourage qu'ils avaient
refait leurs dents ces personnes là qui
ne l'avaient conseillé ben tout le monde
commence à avoir les mêmes problèmes
donc on a vite été contacté par la
Sécurité sociale parce que là aussi
arnaqué au niveau de la Sécu la gonfler
les factures ça limite plein les poches
donc c'est par la suite qu'on a compris
en fait qu'on a été plusieurs à avoir
été arnaqué des dents dévitalisées pour
rien des dents arrachées alors qu'à
certains qui disent je comprends pas
comment on peut vous arracher des dents
pas moi personnellement mais il y a des
personnes à qui j'ai entendu qu'on leur
a fait ce reproche là comment peut-on
vous arracher des dents sans que vous
soyez d'accord mais en fait quand on
vous en dort on vous dit voilà la dent
elle est digitaliser elle est morte il
faut l'enlever c'est un dentiste que
vous avez en face de vous fait confiance
donc Lionel gage et son père Carnot
comparé dans leur procès en appel le
dernier étape sans pour raison médicale
c'est ça il a des problèmes
qui sont mis en cause pour violence
volontaire ayant entraîné une mutilation
ou une infirmité permanente et d'effets
d'escroqueries commis entre 2006 et 2012
dans leur cabinet dentaire des quartiers
nord de Marseille au total 374 victimes
des dentistes se portent partie civile
374 victimes
partie civile dans ce procès qui devrait
durer plus d'un mois jusqu'au 30 juin ce
qu'il aurait reproché c'est d'avoir
promis des sourires de stars aux
passions bénéficiant de la CMU les
passions les plus pauvres qui
bénéficient de la gratuité des soins
d'avoir posé des prothèses de manière
injustifiante dévitalisant des dons ou
encore de facturer des honoraires
particulièrement excessifs en première
instance ils ont été condamnés à 80 ans
de prison pour Lionel le fils et 5 ans
pour Carnot le père lionel est détenu
mais son père est libre sous contrôle
judiciaire les victimes attendent leurs
indemnisations le monde indique que le
fond de garantie des victimes est validé
290 demandes d'indemnisation 290
demandes d'un divinisation alors en
train de vie de millionnaire puisque
selon la sécurité sociale il a posé 28
fois plus de couronnes que la moyenne
des dentistes français 28 fois plus que
la moyenne des dentistes français et
facturer des honoraires 14 fois
supérieur à la moyenne départementale
en 2010 il est ainsi devenu le
chirurgien-dentiste le mieux rémunéré de
l'hexagone avec près de 3 millions
d'euros sur un an avec ces honoraires
au total près de 1,7 millions d'euros de
préjudice une enquête a établi que
l'ancien dentiste des quartiers Nord
s'est constitué un très gros patrimoine
immobilier de 9,5 millions d'euros
possédant des voitures de luxe ou encore
un yacht de 15 mètres
et en précisant qu'il a fait tout ça à
crédit et que c'est justement ce qui lui
donnait cette frénésie apparemment de
vouloir avoir de plus en plus de
passions et de bosser de 6 heures à 20h
c'était des achats à crédits alors
l'avocat les dés pour que son client ne
campe reste pas physiquement au tribunal
mon client a des problèmes de santé
anciens il a une partie du cœur qui est
atrophiée ce qui a nécessité en 2020 la
pose d'un simulat d'un simulateur
cardiaque or il y a un dysfonctionnement
de cet appareil alors que mon client
était en détention j'ai demandé à ce que
ce pacemaker soit changé ça n'a pas été
fait il y a deux semaines mon client
était victime d'un malaise avec perte de
connaissance il a été aux spécialité
spécialisé à Draguignan il est dans un
état d'épuisement et d’essoufflement
continu qui fait qu'il ne pourrait pas
aborder cette épreuve qui est le procès
mais cette semaine il a été extrait de
sa cellule de la prison des Baumettes
puisque un rapport médical conclué que
son état de santé n'était pas
incompatible avec la compaution
va vous donner la justification c'est
incroyable aussi
4133 couronnes posées sur près de 927
patients des actes soi-disant réalisés
en 10 minutes contre plusieurs heures
pour ses confrères
une efficacité qui aurait conduit nos
dentistes à recevoir 70 à 100 patients
par jour
à 100 patients par jour
arriver au box très affaibli il a donné
une justification qui ont révolté des
parties civils présentes dans la salle
je n'ai jamais dit que j'étais le
meilleur dentiste du monde je conteste
les faits
je n'ai jamais commis de fautes
volontaire j'ai peut-être commis
quelques négligions sans le consentement
éclairer des patients c'est en gros il
disait je veux vous avez une dent à
dévitaliser on va en dévitaliser 10 il y
a un problème là je vais vous arracher
10 dents donc en fait les patients qui
sont chez le dentiste le dentiste leur
conseil ça ils disent OK et donc ça
permettait d'alimenter le système et
effectivement
99% des honoraires étaient payés par
l'assurance maladie il y a détecter la
fraude et après avec les dizaines de
patients les centaines de patients
qu'ont porté plainte ça a créé ce procès
incroyable 8 et 5 ans pour un dentiste
c'est tout à fait justifié mais c'est
une peine qui n'avait jamais été vu quoi
alors aujourd'hui on est plus de 10 ans
après comme je l'ai dit vous avez encore
des douleurs ah oui
tant que le problème n'est pas réglé
donc moi je vaux actuellement encore des
experts je
qui essaient d'estimer les dégâts et de
m'aiguiller au mieux ils estiment à
combien les dégâts parce que là c'est
vous agacez votre vie préjudice
en plus c'est par rapport à votre
travail c'est quoi le préjudice parce
que le préjudice il est énorme non c'est
ce chiffre à combien des millions
d'euros je crois dans les 60000 euros 60
000 euros
en fait ils sont pas en mesure de
travailler pendant 10 ans oui ils sont
pas en mesure de pouvoir chiffrer
réellement parce qu'ils ont besoin de
voir ce qui est récupérable ou pas donc
pour ça il faut tout retirer faut voir
ce qu'on peut garder ou pas ce qu'on
peut faire ou pas et donc il y en a
beaucoup où qui ne peuvent pas qui ne se
sentent pas capables de faire ces
travaux là ou alors c'est pas chez
frappe encore les 60.000 euros
pardonnez-moi c'est le chiffrage pour
refaire toute votre sourire mais c'est
pas votre préjudice moral le fait que
vous n'ayez psychologique le fait que
vous n'ayez pas pu travailler vous étiez
mannequin j'ai compris vous avez des 24
ans à l'époque donc pendant 10 ans ça ça
a pas été chiffré pour le moment moi mon
mon problème en fait c'est les dents oui
je comprends que ce soit
psychologiques aussi aujourd'hui vous
attendez donc cet argent pour pouvoir
refaire vos dents et pouvoir repartir
surtout que tout soit pris en charge en
fait pour que tous les trois vous soient
fait en sachant que on n'est pas sûr
d'avoir chacun tout cela somme parce que
en France c'est extrêmement élevé au
niveau des soins dentaires à l'étranger
c'est pas concevable avec le souci qu'on
a eu en coin donc c'est compliqué les
dentistes ont certains avocats nous
conseillent de demander à des dentiste
de nous faire l'avance des soins mais
elle a beaucoup qui refusent parce que
bien sûr à Marseille l'affaire Guedj
j'ai connu de tous les dentistes donc
voilà c'est un cercle vicieux et c'est
long c'est long et on ne voit plus la
fin alors
aujourd'hui vous travaillez ou pas oui
dans la restauration d'accord donc vous
avez dû arrêter votre travail de
mannequin il y a 10 ans
aujourd'hui donc vous attendez qu'une
chose c'est pouvoir refaire vos dons et
repartir cette mariée oui
ils ont parlé tous les jours à votre
mari votre conjoint et tous les jours
j'ai mal j'en peux plus tous les jours
c'est un calvaire
on a bien faire des cauchemars mais
c'est réel c'est à se dire si ça arrive
demain ça casse on fait comment on pour
aller au boulot prenez des antidouleurs
j'imagine mais les antidouleurs ils font
pleurer au bout d'un moment moi on m'a
expliqué que fallait que je me prépare
psychologiquement même à un moment des
réparations à ce que mon visage soit
déformé parce que quand ça touche le
devant du visage quand ils vont devoir
creuser ben tout ça je vais devoir me
préparer à pas me regarder quoi c'est
pas c'est un tout quoi et il faut et
j'appréhende ce moment là aussi merci je
suis pas sûr d'y arriver